und ja wir waren fast am ende vom
waldstück vor michael rimmer erfahren
ging und das gerechnet durchs meer und
mich und noch zwei jetzt drin er ist
immer noch drin war im knie und hannover
[Musik]
ich würde einfach mal interessieren wie
wie ist ihr weg in die
kriegsgefangenschaft gewesen so von
anfang 1945 an vom film bevor sie ja der
weg bis dahin ja ja ich bin ja mit 18
jahre bin ich dann eingezogen worden
und dann kam ich kam ich in die kaserne
nach münchen in die saarstraße und von
dort aus da würde ich wird wurde ich
dann verlegt nach mittenwald und da war
dann die ausbildung und da haben heute
die bergmesse gemacht und da war ich
dann bis bis januar so in dieser
ausbildung am bergsteigen und alles
gemacht herunterlaufen und und dann aber
allen dann wurden sie wurde gefragt
werden führerschein hat mir gemeldet
motorradführerschein kraftfahrzeug und
dann bin ich nach münchen gekommen
da hat man so die befehle hin und her
gefahren und es war ich dann und wann du
hast da wurde dann die 135 im vertrieb
division aufgestellt im laufe des
spätsommers und wie schon gesagt da bin
ich dann dazu gekommen und da war ich
dann beim start haben beim start äußeres
kradfahrer eingeteilt worden und von
dort ging es dann richtung kärnten noch
ist reich rüber und die trauer und da an
von der die trauer ist der flüsse und da
war mir nach dem warum gewesen mit die
ganzen fahrzeuge blüten fahrzeuge und so
weiter
zugmaschinen was hat alles dazu gehört
für die rebellion und von da aus
gegangen dann der krieg das war dann
doch den mai der begann der krieg nach
jugoslawien drüber 1901 sich ja ja es
war dann 41 und im mai war dies auch und
da ging es los nach jugoslawien
januar die stationen gewesen wo deine
stadt stationiert gewesen im land sei
und dort die division in banja luka und
von der kampagne luca aus da bin ich vom
passion zur partnerlook wie immer wieder
gefahren und so und als melder und eines
tages war ich dann in der division
fertig und über noch gewesen dort und
dann fuhr ich wieder zurück zum vater
zurück die straße waren dann eher luca
wunderbare groß ist raus gewesen und
denke holz geht es wieder heim zone und
faso und da ist ein kroatischer der
hübsche kroaten eingeteilt auch als
polizisten und sperma der plötzlich die
straße was mache ich in krems ab und
holt den lastwagen um umfahren von
hinten rutscht weg und trifft man dabei
muss scheinbar ins hinterrad
angeschlossen sein und bringt man den
acht zentimeter
den oberschenkel acht zentimeter und nie
den oberschenkel
jetzt liegt sie doch der fußball denkt
man ja das stück ist weg und dauer in
der nähe auch klar wieso das lazarett
eingerichtet war von den deutschen und
den niederrhein wurden wird in juneau
aus sind in china nutzen doch
aufgeschnitten
das sind alles die die kleinigkeiten die
man so erlebte und dort ausschließen wir
wieder gesund gemacht worden nichts ist
klar und einsatz wieder einsatzfähig
gewesen und es war dann im im januar am
zehnter jahr 1942
da war der kalte winter wenn da herinnen
kennt vielleicht der kalte winter war da
haben die frauen für die soldaten sogar
socken gestritten
antunes ort ist so propagiert gewesen
und dann haben sie so wieder an die
front geschickt und zwar ist man doch
wieder zusammengefasst wurden für die
division dabei dabei das haben wir über
die ukraine muss man mittel war in
krakau in der konzerne in anatolischen
also sei die ware die toiletten
vorgegeben das war doch die wollen wir
hin stehen muss und so weiter
das ist dass ihm stehen alles alles
zugefroren
nochmal aber auch mal drei tage da in
dieser kaserne
das haben wir mal ausgaben freund freund
also einer und sagte guck mal gehen wir
mal nach einem reinen stadt nicht warum
man den starken hörder um sonntag schaut
da gibt es
das freudenhaus und so aber nach
unbedingt brauchen wir nicht ist ja
alles eingerichtet gewesen
grappa und ankommen die die lkw aus
frankreich auf die mussten wir warten da
im and roll und es bis hinten gekommen
also der nachschub 34 dort war man schon
dort nun sind die gekommen dass immer
auf diese lastwägen hinten drauf
er fragte bei hinterbänkler
hintereinander und sahen nach russland
rein und dann den schneetreiben und dann
ist wieder muss wieder freut mich aber
nur normale kleidung make up trage dazu
sie sagten sie seien auf lkws seien sie
nach russland in die ukraine
reingefahren
was hat man damals als soldat dabei
gehabt hatten sie wenigstens kein
gewinde geltung was haben sie dabei dann
also in karabiner klar was maria und
karl p naja aber die kabine horst am
lastwagen gehabt da die die haben mir
erst bekommen wie immer wieder dort also
stationiert worden sein dann hörst ein
karabiner gelegt aber mehr nicht und
sonst rucksack oder saison hat der
hostie normale ausrüstung gehabt die mir
so ich dir ja da stehen schon bewusst
immer hast du schon rucksack wusstest du
deine sorgen heute hass und brot beutel
und und das was halt so da dann normale
ausrüstung bloß morgen ja man ist hier
nicht viel viel nein im janker kam luca
kopp den schuldigen arnim 0 und
blutbeutel gehabt und dem spruch
geschehen und die sie sagen wird und die
waffen oder so was die hat man jetzt
bekommen wo die einheit zusammen
gestellt worden ist als 1
als kompanie oder ist zug was weiß ich
wieviel 100 stück da war es vielmehr
eine kompanie und haben wir dann los und
da und uns dann irgendwann ein gebiet
eingesetzt
da war heute wie lücken waren und es war
alles verschneit da haben das war die
ukraine und der ukraine haben wir dann
in die sie da waren bauern und da haben
wir so ein bauernhaus aufgeteilt worden
ganz vorn ein kommando wieder obwohl die
firma ihre ziegen drin gehabt noch zwei
stück nach dass uns nur essen gemacht
und dann kommst du nur suchen geben also
richtig typisch russisch gern gesehene
menschen nicht zu alt und damals war der
ukrainisch-russischen haben sie jetzt
wieder verlegt waren das hin auch in der
gegend nicht weit weg und da war nicht
so viel schnee das war total muli und da
und runder und der monitor kleine
ortschaft dort unsere feldküche
degradiert machte mir auch nicht mehr
euch posten war mir da ausgestattet
nicht aufpassen ob der übergang über den
buckel und ja ein bisserl und gesten
dieser puffer moorhusen aufgetaucht ist
oder aber später von den rosen und mir
wochen verspätung von uns und vergesst
mir runter und dann hinterher schaust du
erstmal wir haben die russen nicht mehr
gesehen obwohl alles ziemlich frei war
schön so hügel und zu gucken da warum es
hier eben wenn man so ein buch wie
hinten kommt vielleicht schon
wir haben den zeugnissen sina wann oder
wie weit waren 13 meter lang
ja das waren viel mehr sind aber mal
1000 und 2000 auf also ja gut und schön
angst das ist ein schock moment nicht
und da gehst die rückmeldung dass wir
dabei und mir waren kam zurück hat sich
um am hang entlang
es war so ruhig und am hang entlang
kommen sie der russin gezeigte pferde
gerieten nicht
da schaut es nicht gut aus wir mit
unseren gewähren lust zusammengekauft ja
gut und es ging vorbei und die haben
dann zunehmen wenn mehr runterkommen
nichts an wirklich wunderbar so verteilt
auch weiter drüben so dass sie dem er
denn uns umsehen umziehen wollten dann
die waren an den start
hoffmann ja gemerkt das war große
einheit ja gut aber für uns war der
befehl haben wir mussten zu rücken
konnten uns nicht verteidigen da ging es
los und sie waren einen nachschub
einheit die sozusagen in der mulde
stationiert war ja ja ja wie viele leute
waren sie ja vielleicht hundert
vielleicht 100 die rüstung sicherung
waren auch soja die fontäne zu erzählen
zwar haben wir keine keine elitäre armee
die oder uns gegenüber stand aber trotz
alledem man ja anders und kann man von
oben runter also hat simons trick wenn
man immer mehr kümmern er wir müssen uns
zurückziehen
das sieht man den leichten hang hoch von
opel dagegen gehalten und mittelbar
schuss aber du kannst du dir auf halten
mit dem vorgeworfen
und dann ging es zurück nach fast um
aber wie gesagt also etwa 700 ja auch
jetzt
ich kann immer laufen da bin ich quasi
und herr leben gelaufen längst nicht
mehr so wild dass hannover auch noch hat
mir seine dann denen entkommen so zu
sagen und nicht gegen an geworden und es
ist eine einheit von uns uns hingegen
kommen die home server so panzerfahrzeug
dabei hat oder so was
wir haben ab und dann irgendwo in der
scheune übernachtet und machen dann
tagsüber in anderen abschnitt auch sowas
ähnlich ist eingesetzt worden aber da
war nichts mehr los und fotos hat sie
das ganze dann aufgeteilt und wir kamen
irgendwie zu unseren einheiten
und dann kam ich zu meiner zum beispiel
brasilien zurück und zwar auf die krim
und dann war ich
und die hatten da auf der krim kurz
zuvor das wir kommen haben die er das ja
das ist es statt denn auf der krim
eingenommen die deutschen und wir
gekommen sind da hat man bei erzählt der
spaziergang
die haben es sehr gebildet die deutschen
die chance zu bekommen also man hat sehr
viele tote mann und gelegen was dem mir
erzählt haben das habe ich nicht gesehen
und haben die stadt eingenommen
ganz kurz noch jahre und sie sagten die
deutschen haben dort fürchterlich
gewütet haben sie ja heute haben wir
mein kollege erzählt was heißt das also
haben als er alles um gemacht was mw
kann wenn es eines kumpels heim war
nicht durch jetzt weiß ich nicht ob die
schlacht nicht gesehen und waren halt so
viele tot also
räume müssen hat man 9000 wir dürfen
also es ist gar nicht bloß von der
erzählung von meinem speziellen auf
jeden fall war es nicht einfach doch
sich die zu erhoben
und dann waren die linie richtung herz
um die differenz kann zu haben und mir
kommen dann ich war dann in einem hotel
unter und es war genau am meer gelegen
habe sogar mal im schwarzen meer baden
können
in der zeit wo wir unterkommen wo sie
jetzt nicht genau welche datum und da
waren wir vielleicht heraus schon
etliche vielleicht sogar stationiert bis
dann weiterging und kam der angriff vom
8 mai oder auch wieder anfangs mai
richtung herrsching kerzen
da haben wir nur gewartet wann kommen
wir jetzt hinweis nächste einheit wo wir
sie hinterlegt einmal gedacht vielleicht
müssen wir über den campus so sievers
surfski mir auch mal gedacht aber es ist
da ist nichts draus gewesen da haben wir
ad li na ja wochen gelegen ruhig und
dann kam der befehl richtung sewastopol
dann ist passiert wissen warum sonst der
verstärkung gebrauchen um steves er
nicht woanders hin sondern noch mal nach
sowohl da war man dann dort in
sewastopol business gefallen ist
das habt ihr gehört was sowohl die die
stärkste c und langfristige konsum der
welt gewesen und man sich somit bekommen
noch und wir hatten dann hat es geheißen
ja da ist zum schluss noch eine elite in
der einheit gekommen
die heute den rest dann in der stadt
erledigt hat oft erst wenn man so sagen
will erledigt nur eingenommen
zum schluss geht es nur hand um
häuserkampf von sony auktionsschluss wie
genauso wie in stalingrad war nur
häuserkampf bis zum letzen mal sowas
wenn man da mit drin ist das kann sich
ja heute lebt das kann man sie nicht
aussterben
du bist da kann man fast samt ulrich ne
das ist eine damals eine ganz kurze
frage noch mal dazu dann wenn sie das
jetzt so beschreiben häuserkampf bis zum
letzten
was haben sie davon mitbekommen sind sie
selbst diese pionier gewesen sind sie
als stadtnah selbst sollen die kämpfende
truppe daher nein ich war da nicht hin
an der vordersten front weil ich wollte
beim bradl jun staub ich habe das heute
als melder man muß wieso sieht die für
die vision zur kompanie wieder vorgehen
und im dt liebe mitteln und zu das habe
ich mehr draus funktion gehabt nicht
aber sie haben die verletzten kameraden
und die gefallenen die haben sie gesehen
von ihrer seite denn sie wollen ja wir
waren dann mal mein chef weiter
und dann ist der chef mir also noch ein
paar wochen dabei und sammer 100 fahren
in die stadt nach sewastopol wird es
gefallen war
in der hobby heute statt
ich habe den trümmerhaufen erwähnen ist
ein bisserl durchgefahren
draußen das war es und dann sagen wir
als division wieder abgezogen worden und
simon nach norden gekommen und dann das
sagen mir mehr richtung bahnhof und
unsere aufgabe war da eben neuer die
soldaten zu versorgen mit nachschub und
so weiter knüppel dinge bauen wofür sind
sie will damit der nachschub nach vorne
rollt da für das nun mit fahrzeuge der
vorfahren hat kenner zur herstellung
nicht also so eine art straße ja ja
beides war es und gebiet marmor und von
dort gehen wir mal wieder zurück braucht
man immer so lang
und das hat sie dann ja erübrigt opitz
tolingo noch mal gefallen ist also die
nummer angerufen hat das weiß ich alles
nicht wir haben von dort an zurückkommen
school land und kurl antwort an unser
unser letzte station und das sind die
drei länder nicht
jetzt weiß er nicht genau wo man erstmal
zurück und es ist halt dann immer wieder
nicht nach vorne gegangen immer wieder
zurück
und da hatten wir dann einen einsatz und
zwar ist beim kurland und da waren die
melder die immer zur front vorgehen zur
linie die melder die sind immer
beschossen worden
und da waren scharfschützen und hatten
wir den auftrag die erste kompanie
das war dann ein einziger einzuführen
und
zehn mal vielleicht und haben wir das
waren sehr waldstück und nach dem krieg
war wiese und unten war wieder weit und
in den wald stück das handeln beschossen
worden
und da haben wir dann das waldstück
durchkämmen müssen sagt man dadurch
kämen und schauen wo sind da irgendwie
die scharfschützen de wo immer diese
leute die die melder beschießen
in etlichen erschossen ja und ja wir
waren fast am ende vom grundstück
einfach mal grimmen ging ja habe mir
vorher hingegen ja sowas noch nichts
runde erst mal schauen sich dann müssen
erst mal schauen was ist die lage
wo sind die scharfschützen und jan os x
und ich waren an der rechten seite da
und schaue mir aber fast die kerls sehen
da hinten drehen
die haben sie hinein ein loch verschanzt
so dass man die ja nicht gleich um kann
und und der schon gemerkt dass sie da
wieder neugierig bin aber mal hand
überladen und ausgerechnet durchs mia
und mich und noch 23
er ist immer noch im knie und hannover
verlagen gratisblätter und alles was
verletzt kunst hat im frühsommer
gescheitert da war mehr drin
er ist erster in der das verkapselt sich
dampf und der obere ist heraus gemacht
worden
er war mehr in fleisch und da bin ich
zurück gekommen in salzhausen verband
stelle heute der uns noch mal probiert
und dann hoffe ich
im lazarett gewinner eingetroffen der
wurm ihr motto zu sich gesagt nimm du
mir eine maschine bist du ein gibt man
denkt wer war mir gehen zwei mann zurück
wegen der verletzung und und den mann
hobby dann später im lazarett noch mal
getroffen
in münster kreisen der war früher haben
wir bei der pferde staffel
die sind alle dann mittlerweile wieder
eingesetzt werden so komponiert die
leute waren zu wenig geworden und
hergershausen durchaus und darum noch
einmal ein angriff macht die gekaperten
und er hat dann am kopf streifschuss
erwischt der schlafschule sahen wir
zählt dort 3 jürgen stahl heim und dann
gucken und streift durch den stall im
surf immunisierung war das und so
gezielt die munition nicht dass manche
die scharfschützen getroffen und hast du
es wichtig nicht aber der wahnsinn ja
die schon auch das ist man immer wenn
man nicht immer dann von drin ist ist
man es trotzdem auch wieder nicht sie
sagten sie wären verletzt worden durch
die granatsplittern und sind sie dann
nachdem sie verbunden worden sind direkt
wieder in dieses waldstück um weiter zu
kämpfen
ist das richtig da bin ich immer dazu
nicht mehr naja ich bin ja dann ist das
redcoon ins lazarett von lotterie das
ist nun mal reinkommen aber glück gehabt
nicht weil das wort es gibt und das ist
in dem fall in die empfindlichen sachen
wenn es wird gleichwohl sind wir schnell
wieder aber das war wieder verletztem
knie
die beugung da in der hand geht und was
er nach dem sie darum noch irgendwie ja
gut weil sie mal schauen aber wie es
weitergeht aber aber der krieg war nicht
verwaist
wir waren dabei das war ja anfangs in
kurland moment
wir haben davon runter kummer und da war
man in kurland ja der krieg wand und in
vorbei aber der krieg war dann in
kurland so richtig ja alle langsames
absetzen
wir sind sie noch ungefähr waren das war
war das 1944 als sie verletzt also
verwundet wurden und dann nach hause
gekommen sind
44 und wird sie wahnsinnig gern 45 haben
wir nochmal danach schickte ins kulant
und von dort hatte immer rückwärts im
moment wo man denkt jetzt ist man zu
hause ist verletzt
vielleicht lag es dass bis heute endlich
den krieger siehst das denkmuster
prävention so weit ist alles stalingrad
kaputt und so weiter
man war nicht voller zuversicht
aber wie gesagt das watt ist na ja und
da haben wir nochmal nach liebe und da
video gesagt das hat immer langsam
zurück wenn man schon kriegsendes an
und da ist doch da auch die mai gekommen
und da hat sie dies natürlich cds
gesammelt und wir wurden in ein großes
lager war vertrag verfrachtet und es war
dann an der grenze ungefähr bei uns
schon richtung deutschland und der
grenze und von dort wurden wurden wir
noch ein gesetz minen zu suchen
da waren wir ungefähr 44 wochen noch da
oben den großen lager nur bedingt naja
vielleicht geht es jetzt doch bald heim
zu nicht und dann kam der bisher
und der hat uns die haare geschnitten
august ist vorbei der an der gangster in
das lager und von dort aus die großen
russen balkon ausgestattet gewesen und
zwar mit britschen die wahren unterteilt
eine so hoch da unten worden hat ein
gelegenen übernommen und anderen um ohne
nebeneinander und es war dann im sommer
da ist dann sommer gewesen
trotz großer hitze es war dann juli
es war im juli um beim abitur war zu
ende mai war zu ende im juni war mal da
oben noch im juli ist immer noch zivile
intendierten nationen das hat man ja
schon gesagt und dann kommen ja ja und
an der transport darunter der hat
ungefähr die zehn tage gedauert musst
immer wieder halten
ja das ist das wesen der würden uhr
eingeschoben wird nicht der hkv plan
gehabt nicht und da haben sie in der
zeit vielleicht ich wollte immer so
genau so drei vier mal aussteigen lassen
wonder habe ihm dann ganz wenig essen
durchgekommen eigentlich nicht so stell
ich alles gewesen darunter der vaart ist
es was gegeben aber doch nicht mehr nur
wieder mal vor russische knäckebrot
aber es war alles zum überleben richtig
wie ist die stimmung in seinem werk
spricht man ja und einen ratgeber für
nicht stumpf da kommt man kann keine
großen erzählungen machen zum anderen
ist der druck natürlich die kosten
es war die defizite und noch dazu imago
ja das haben wir dort in lager
angekommen und es war ein hollein ein
lager von einer von einem sägewerk und
die haben dort die piraten gehabt die
haben die ist er vermietet an die
militär und die arbeitsstellen wir haben
wir von dort aus dann da war noch
rumänen in stationiert in den lagern und
die hunde die die küche gemacht darum
die die kriege die ersten tage noch
gemacht die haben alles nike haben die
fische mit samtig reden alles klar denn
dass nach einer so viele gewesen und
ring gehabt und ohne mängel so operieren
das wurde anfang des 20 du hast dann nur
suppe kriegt und rot morgen suppe und
road to be und brot 200 gramm brot und
mieter hatten wir zwei kleine dose touch
gegeben
es war sehr breit hier sie drei oder
erbsen 33 und da hat es vier wochen lang
gegeben dass wieder die nächste sendung
kommuniziert ist das nächste mal wieder
anderen freigelegt und das war so die
ernährung also da ging es ums nackte
überleben eigentlich ja schon viel
gesehen und da war und da waren wir
heute in verschiedene arbeitsgruppen
eingeteilt worden
und da haste die latten darüber drogen
geprägt durch alles handarbeit a bisserl
und dann bist du zurück ins lager das
würde eine arbeits teil den man machen
konnte war aber nicht immer dieselben
manchmal bisher eingeteilt worden macht
man nicht
und dann hat seine elektro stand sie
gegeben haben doch zu batterien und
sowohl scheinbar alles hergestellt diese
gruppe dvd format verdient
da wo der handel park übrig geblieben
weil die die du musst ja so viel
erwirtschaften dass du dass die
unterkunft bezahlen uns essen bezahlen
kannst
und die haben damals so 10 oder was
rubel 3 kam bekommen
es war die gruppe und nah war ich habe
mal auch in einer anderen gruppe die
sagt kummer da war ernte da ist was
haben wir da gemacht da haben wir
ehrlich macht und kartoffelernte war das
aber alles mit der hand darauf wohl
keine maschine die aus gram und und
alles alles nicht da wo er auch wieder
mal zwei wochen hin in cardiff lehrern
die du hast wieder entkommt meine güte
alle aufspringen
darum waren wir so mit heim genommen
haben dürfen
brüssel die großen in der werbe- und
dass das wieder mehr in die suppen
lenkung ist der hat der kosten zu ändern
aber weiter wegen mehr drin aber mir hat
man vielleicht heute 103
[Gelächter]
ja und da wurde ich dann krank es war
dann oktober die ärzte haben immer
wieder untersucht wegen fieber naja
warum sagt man ja was so wie er aussieht
die schwarz mit ideo mich wenn mich
rocksongs mit deren mutter hat mir der
war nicht uns immer die schwimmer mal
saison nicht oder ich hier eigentlich
sogar recht denn hätte er zehn russische
das will nur reden immer so quasi
temperatur also business night ich weiß
nicht wo mir wieder chor temperatur
gehabt aber wieder nicht klappt was das
war haben sie nicht rausgefunden
wir sehen in salaten eingelegt zu den
lungen schwinn sich liegen da war doch
wieder acht top teams merkt das ist doch
hören der lunge nicht ob und was sie da
wieder raus es war zwar alles
gefangenschaft und siehe da wieder raus
ja gut und wie schon gesagt und dann ist
es doch mal mit gange und ich war wieder
frei im lager und was kam dann wieder
dazu der pazifist ja ich muss natürlich
wiederum dann bin ich wieder in die
sanierung komme isolierzimmer mit drei
mann ungefähr tobit david downes und ein
bisserl das war alles jetzt muss sie da
wieder so unser lang warten
bist du da negativ ist und dann in der
zwischenzeit diesen tanz bord gegangen
hey du wärst eigentlich doch schwach
kann es doch einmal mit kummer
natürlich warten auch immer wieder krank
und st und dann ist der befund kommen
kunden sind
[Musik]
katrin riedel ergebnis gut negativ und
und dann entlassen worden
und dann bin ich auch zu wenig um die
uhr zum transport kümmern und das höhere
transport wurden nach stetten aber damit
draußen oldies segelschulen sowas mit
mit gummisohle und was daraus zu haben
oder wieder an die kleidung von militär
musste damals samstag dann sagen kaufen
und dann bis eingeleitet worden
und ja das hat lange gedauert hin und
her und ist und den zählungen und vista
so weit war der transport so weit fertig
ist was du die ganze zeit im moment
gefragt im bett es ging der marsch von
von lager circa fünf kilometer zum
bahnhof es musste alles nur leisten
dienstag zum bahnhof und nochmal
eingestiegen in den in baku und sang
zurückgefahren und ja da hat man immer
belangt das video heraus wohin da wo es
wieder den kadi oder waren wir der
einheit oder was das war nicht sicher
nicht eigentlich ist ja geschehen und
sabine bis nach frankfurt an der oder in
frankfurt oder oder
da war dann die entlassung stelle ich
und du hast dann ist er entlassen worden
und bis noch über die sogenannte ddr
musste ich noch mal jetzt muss täter
wieder kurz vor dem grenzübergang nach
dem westen darüber weil sie sah den ort
nimmer musste dann noch einmal halt
morgen und über nacht noch mal
und wurde dennoch einmal fieber gemessen
und ich hab da auch der drei ist fieber
aber das geht nicht schütteln mal runter
und und noch wenig doch am anderen tag
mit zum transport nach hause gekommen
und auf der bühne stehen und noch am
gleichen tag wieder ein paar waren
vielleicht 323 heimkehrer alexander
tchigir und da bin ich halt von zug über
unser man anzug und der gene die nächste
überraschung
es ist mein vater mein vater kommt von
nürnberg der ring bei menowin
malerarbeiten zu hilfsarbeiten machen
keine reparaturen gemacht zusätzlich zur
rente und für daheim ihren songs doch
oder freitag also meine mutter war immer
so am fenster gesehen hat immer runter
schaut wenn die zug leute gekommen sind
wer kunden alles und davor teuer werden
dann unter bei haid der wohl herum geht
so dass contis erkannt man mutige und
das war das war die heimkehr den vater
dazu treffen
das war das alles hin satz wenn sie in
der gefangenschaft hat einen irgendwann
mal erlebens mut verlassen wird wenn man
gar nicht weiß wie es weitergeht kommt
man da jemals aus denkt man dass man da
für immer bleibt die hoffnung stirbt nie
aus der oft immer wieder dass erneut
wie sie heimkommen aber wann du hast du
eine vorstellung machen können
das ist heute durch das immer wieder
grumpy heimgefahren monsters immer
wieder wegen und zum schluss und mir
haben wir dann da war ich schon genau in
den haushalt gebaut habe es dann und
dann hat es war dann wohl ja da war man
schon mit solisten in späteren jahren
von der familie und darf am holz eisen
ja die die gefangenen bekommen pro die
wollen die schwangerschaft pro tag einen
eine mark entschädigung
es war natürlich wieder ein aufrufen
haus zu die entscheidungen bekommen und
zwar aus dem tschad wirklich so eine 1
eine mark pro tag 300 so und so vital
vitaler jetzt haben denn nur die hälfte
gezahlt nur ja ja ja wir haben die 500
oder so sagt mark plus gelenkt und so
drei audio ist und mehreren 1
das haus hat wir ja so geht's also drei
jahren und war jetzt also wenn man jetzt
diesen tag des kriegsendes in den acht
mal war es ein tag an dem sie sich
gefreut haben oder war klar dass da ihr
persönlicher krieg war sie noch gar
nichts ändern die vorfreude der krieg zu
ende war es dann hinterher geschehen ist
frau mannschaft und mit dem hat man ja
gar nicht gerechnet der mühle gerechnet
man kommt vielleicht heim zum sevilla wo
man hat die order oder geschnitten
gerückt hatte wusste man das ist vorbei
ist vorerst auf der pritsche lagen haben
sie auch tagebuch geschrieben oder
beschrieben oder was gehen dann dafür
gedanken
hat man aber schreibt erstmal gar nichts
zum schreiben kommt und zweitens ist mir
sympathisch das thema ist immer der mann
eigentlich ist da man noch etwas
festlegt oder was das alles für jeden
nachher ist weihnacht was ist so
rückblickend wenn sie den ganzen krieg
und die kriegsgefangenschaft anschauen
was war ihr schlimmstes erlebnis was sie
da hatten schlimmste immer so wie du
stehst du mal dort und da und gegen kuba
begrüßt der hangkante vor der nase das
in den angenehm aber mal das ist
einmalig hat jetzt das gewesen was
andere wollen wir darauf wieder
zurückgezogen worden seien und oder oder
andere erleben diese wurst so mitten in
der kälte durch die gegend transportiert
wirst wohl alles aber es ist vorbei gang
hat es überlebt denkt man immer land
ich hoffe das wird es uns nimmer so
ausführlich erzählt was sonst nicht
soviel unteren teil zu tun
na das ist so denkt schon mal wieder
schlafstätte und da mal wieder dass vor
davos wieder das waldstück siehst du
siehst du wieder wir sind jetzt momentan
forscht ist und da ist es ist uns schon
vorher im rahmen zu oder du denkst du
dass gunter neuwieder reich aber ist
verfolgte ich nur in dem sinn dass
nannte kley weiterschlafen kunst mehr
das ist und du willst eigentlich konnte
trudelt ist das fällt heute einmal
und so zu wenn sie sich die generation
die jüngeren generationen heutzutage so
anschauen da sehen sie menschen die
große sorge haben vor dingen wie
klimawandel vor rechtspopulismus und
vielleicht auch noch vor flüchtlingen
und anderen dingen wenn sie den menschen
eine botschaft senden würden aus ihrer
sicht mit ihrer erfahrung als sie so alt
waren haben sie im krieg gestanden haben
sie gekämpft
was wäre das sagen sie zu denen halb so
schlimm
oder sagen sie zu dem passt schon das
wird schon alles funktionieren oder
sagen sie ihr müsst wirklich aufpassen
was was ist ihre botschaft natürlich
schwierig ganze antworten zu geben weil
die der klimawandel der story aber wer
sie auswirkt im endeffekt das weiß
keiner
das ist das eine
und was soll man als zweite ist was
anderes ob man das als populismus jaja
da kennt ja aufpassen das ist und das
ist da können sie mal sehen wir sind da
draußen gewesen und haben mit dem
teleskop durch die westlichsten so
schlimmes erlebt wie im zweiten
weltkrieg
egal ob es in welcher stelle er gekämpft
hatte gelebt hat das ist furchtbar
gewesen dass ihr euch zum beispiel nimmt
und nicht noch mehr gegen diese typen da
also sich euch zeigt dass dies nicht so
wieder noch mal sowas gibt aber es man
sieht ja es gibt leute die sind so
eingestellt seien bringen blumen
allerletzte frage wenn ihre enkelin oder
ihre urenkelin sie jetzt fragen würden
ob europa wenn ich meine zukunft so sehe
was würdest du sagen kann ich positiv
oder negativ in die zukunft sehen was
würden sie sagen ja wir sagen schaut
positiv ins leben es gibt immer wieder
licht nicht nur nicht nur dunkel
also wir haben ganz herzlich sei dank
nichts zu tun haben